I'm oddly Bozkurt I was research fellow
quite a long time at Harvard Kennedy
School almost seven years
I'm civil engineer I made a research
about the Constitution of the developing
countries a telescope also I'm the
chairman of a business that we are
working in Saudi Arabia Kuwait at this
time Iraq Afghanistan and other Middle
East countries
what can accelerate growth in Arab world
actually this is the subject that I
wanna say a few words about that
first of all in all the countries
the free-market economic accelerate the
words accelerate the growth goodbye is
one of the good sample in this region if
you put the lots of regulation and
government control and
stop the moving the people all around so
this stops this is the most important
factor to stop growth if any businessman
would like to go to any Arab country
he needs to get visa he needs to get
permission and he is not allowed to stay
there more than three five days and this
kind of regulations and also anything
that you import from outside again you
meet lots of obstacles that stops the
ground another most important thing is
that
to
move the money to bring money inside to
take out communication and so many other
freedoms all say acting the business are
important to really encourage or
discourage the growth the money will not
come to a country easily unless they
feel safe if the investors knows that
they bring the money here in the country
they have to have first of all the third
wall legal access to protect their money
to accelerate the growth needs money
technology and knowledge if you don't
have all these things you cannot
accelerate the growth in order to do
that you have to have
you have to give their confidence to the
people who are coming to the country to
create the job beyond the local people
who creates the job also it there has to
be some encouragement and initiative for
the local people to cooperate with the
foreign companies to get the technology
and other things at the end of the world
I would like to say that as much as you
free in working and environment that
needs to work you make a sustainable
growth in the country